[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
exploring a little lesson in harry
potter history and taking a look at the
history of the fabled animagus
more specifically i'm going to be
revealing to you all the first three
recorded
but unregistered anime guy
that is the first three ancient witches
and wizards that were able to shapeshift
an animagus simply put is a witch or
wizard that is able to transform
themselves into an animal and back again
animagus is a combination of the word
animal and the greek word magus meaning
animal wizard
it is an extremely rare and difficult
ability to master so much so that it
requires you to register your knowledge
of this ability with the ministry but
that wasn't necessary in a pre-ministry
world an animagus will typically have an
animal form they transform into that is
closely linked to their personality and
inner traits further to this the
animagus form of a witch or wizard will
almost always resemble their patronus
form as well
throughout the series we're introduced
to quite a few anime guy
mcgonagall a cat pettigrew a rat series
black a dog james potter a stag rita
skeeter a beetle and if you're thinking
that this list looks short well then
you'd be right becoming an animagus is
no easy feat in fact so few people have
actually achieved this magical feat that
the ministry of magic requires all anime
guy to register their animaker's status
but the ancient witches and wizards i
want to talk about today
existed in a pre-ministry era in fact
some of these witches and wizards were
from an entirely different part of the
world all together
i'm going to work backwards starting
with the third known animagus and
working my way towards the first
recorded animagus to grace the wizarding
world
let's get into it morgana leffey
in case you weren't already aware the
morgana left from harry potter mentioned
on a chocolate frog card in the series
was inspired by a pseudo-historical
figure most commonly referred to by some
derivation of the same name
morgan morgen just morgana you name it
further to this if we look at her in a
pseudo-historical context we can see
where inspiration was drawn for the
witch in harry potter morgana is a tough
pseudo-historical figure to summarize
because across many pieces of literature
she has been reintroduced with so many
different names titles and abilities
perhaps the most interesting thing about
morgana's character however is her moral
ambivalence and how it evolved through
folklore early appearances of morgan do
not elaborate her character beyond her
role as a goddess a fae a witch or a
sorceress generally benevolent and
related to king arthur as his magical
savior and protector her prominence
increased over time as did her moral
ambivalence and in some texts there is
an evolutionary transformation of her to
an antagonist the concept of morgana
that we're most familiar with first
appears in writer jeffrey of monmouth's
work entitled vita mullini or the life
of merlin which was written in 1150
in this version of vita mullini morgana
is referred to as morgen
and name which means seabourn
the name survived in middle welsh as
mauryan and the cognate form in old
irish is muygen the name of a
shape-shifting female saint commonly
associated with the sea
hold on a shape-shifter this ties in
beautifully with harry potter we first
hear morgana lafey in the harry potter
universe when ron mentions that he has
about six of her chocolate frog card
i've got morgana again and i've got
about six of her chocolate frog cards
generally feature my iconic witches and
wizards of history so the fact that she
made the cut is a testament to her
prominence as a historical figure even
in the harry potter universe her card
makes it very clear that she was a very
powerful dark witch and this directly
sums up the version of organa that the
harry potter universe adopted
we got the evil morgana not the morally
righteous one provided that her car
describes her as a very powerful witch i
think that it's reasonable to assume
that morgana was extremely versed in the
dark arts possessing knowledge of all
the dark spells that we are accustomed
to and perhaps and many more
however what's interesting about morgana
is that despite being evil she possessed
immense knowledge of powerful healing
abilities we generally associate healing
and the ability to heal with those that
are morally good or righteous but
morgana contradicts this but what's one
of the most interesting aspects about
morgana well she was an animagus not the
first animagus ever to grace the
wizarding world but she was up there
turns out morgana could transform into a
bird at will
and can you guess what type of bird well
that's unconfirmed but i've got a theory
on this because the pseudo-historical
figure of morgana goes by many names i
decided to look at the associations with
each and as it turns out morgen means
seabourn
what this tells me is that morgana
likely transformed into some kind of
seabird
which seabird in particular is unclear
although i'd venture to say something
like baheren cleaner the origins of
wizard kind go back many many many years
in fact they go so far back that there
is a lot that simply isn't known about
the history of the wizarding world
however what we do know is that one of
the first known members of wizard kind
to exist in europe was a witch by the
name of cleaner who presided there
sometime in the middle ages
cleaner was a famous irish druidess and
notably appears on a chocolate frog card
in the harry potter series
at one point harry picks up a chocolate
frog card with a picture of her while
she was scratching her nose
cleaner was a powerful druidess and her
abilities were vast including of course
the ability to transform her main
animagus form was that of a sea bird the
same as morgana but it has also been
expressed that her unparalleled skill in
transfiguration even allowed her to turn
herself into things like waves
crazy furthermore always travelling
along with cleaner were three magical
birds that could cure the sick by
singing them to sleep however i'll say
this the concept of cleaner in harry
potter was of course inspired by the
cleaner of irish mythology a goddess of
love and beauty he traveled with three
magical birds that cured the sick
falco isalon
alright now you might be thinking
cleaner and morgana were both around as
far back as the medieval era
so when on earth did falco isilon the
first ever recorded animagus exist
well as it turns out falco isalon was a
greek wizard who existed sometime
between the years 700 and 480 bc
meaning he was around well before the
existence of cleaner and morgana in fact
it turns out that ancient greece
produced a lot of powerful witches and
wizards back in the day as if you'll
remember from my acrysis video the man
who purportedly created the dementors
was also from ancient greece
anyway not much is actually known about
falco other than the fact that he was
the first ever recorded animagus it's
unknown if he was the first wizard to
discover the process entirely or if he
was just the first one to be recognized
in history as being able to transform
his animagus form is just as his name
would suggest a falcon pretty cool if
you ask me interestingly falco is
actually the former scientific name of
the european merlin bird merlin in harry
potter was the most powerful wizard to
have ever lived so perhaps there was
some inspiration drawn for falco's name
there behind the scenes like the others
on this list valko was of course also
immortalized on a chocolate frog card
for being the first ever animagus
and that concludes the list for the
first three recorded anime guy
closing thoughts of mine well i thought
it was interesting that all three of
them ended up being birds
with the vast possibilities for
potential enemas forms you'd think
there'd be some more variety there i
wonder why
did you guys know about these three
comment down below also if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel
until next time remember imperfect
understanding is often more dangerous
than ignorance
[Music]
you